Auntie didn't Auntie didn't say you're
stupid she says the girls are stupid
when they get back with the guy and then
complain about him cheating so like you
make his life a living hell you chose to
get back with him and maybe yeah maybe
yeah maybe she couldn't forgive you
couldn't let go yeah so she has to leave
maybe she's just thinking about the
money she would get if she divorced him
that she could start again I think that
but she should have gonna find another
billionaire to match your money then I I
do think he was wrong though because I
do I do believe that if a woman was
there from the start then you owe her
that level of loyalty for helping you
get to the position you got to I only
believe that if he remarries or finds a
new woman then he'd just do the [__] you
like because she's buying into a
lifestyle that she can never really I
want to know if she gets divorced or she
could give the teacher off oh no of
course not she'll be smart to do prenup
just checking yeah I hope she didn't
bring up oh [__] it's not enough why do